[Musique]
non ça fait pas ces preuves parce que le
meilleur comparatif c'est toujours de
regarder ce qui se passe à l'échelle
européenne la france est le 15e pays
européens de la sécurité routière
les résultats sont donc franchement pas
bon et on essaie un peu de camoufler
tout ça en essayant de de tordre
collectif pour leur faire dire ce qu'ils
ne disent pas et on se vit pas puisqu'il
ya moins d'accidents alors c'est que
tout va bien
non non ça va pas bien le problème c'est
que la france a focalisé toute la
sécurité routière sur une seule arme
le radar est sur un seul moyen d'y
remédier donc le radar et sur une seule
cause la vitesse ça peut pas fonctionner
la vitesse quand bien même on lui
attribue à les 30% des accidents
ça veut dire que quand même 70 % des
accidents qui sont liées à autre chose
et tant qu'on se battra contre
uniquement la vitesse dans passera à
côté du reste et puis le radar ça sera
jamais la bonne solution des pays
nordiques s'en passe avec des vitesses
moyennes plus élevés que les nôtres
d'ailleurs et ça fonctionne très bien
nous en france
eh bien on continue à taper on donne
l'impression que la seule chose qui
fonctionne c'est le discours du
matraquage et puis au final on finit par
s'auto comparer alors la france dit
regardez comme on est bon on est passé
de 18 mille à trois mille morts oui mais
les autres pays ont fait beaucoup mieux
que nous donc non il faut l'avouer on
aimerait parce qu'on s'est trompé on a
tous focalisés sur les radars ça
rapporte peut-être de l'argent mais
c'est pas l'armé numéro 1 de sécurité
routière dans les années 70 il y avait
effectivement que ça a été rappelée 18
morts à peu près pas par an à tel point
que les hôpitaux avaient alerté les
pouvoirs publics et après les premières
mesures qui ont été prises c'est les
premières mesures de communes la
ceinture de sécurité et paris ensuite il
ya eu les premières limitations de
vitesse mais on n'avait pas
effectivement dans les années 70 et ça
ça comme ça quand même amélioré les
choses en terme de parce que 18000 mort
c'est un peu beaucoup
et donc effectivement je vais pas dire
qu'on est passé de 18 mille à trois
mille cinq cents uniquement à que les
radars ça chez mc oran alors les radars
on peut en penser ce qu'on en veut par
exemple le royaume uni qui est largement
mis en grade à ras des résultats bien
meilleurs que les nôtres
alors il ya peut-être pas que ça je suis
d'accord mais enfin il ya aussi la
privatisation je peux pas y être
favorable pourquoi parce que ça
sous-entend qu'on va confier de la
sécurité à une société privée et ça
c'est pas possible
alors j'entends des gens tant que la
société ne va faire que conduire le
véhicule
ok pas de problème mais regardez à quel
point c'est ubuesque
si demain cette voiture conduite par une
société privée voir quelqu'un qui a
tellement picoler quillan petit tube sur
la route elle ne peut pas l'arrêter
elle ne peut même pas le verbaliser
parce que ce ne sont pas les forces de
l'ordre imaginons quelqu'un qui passe à
180 km heure sur une petite route
départementale la société privée ne peut
rien faire
elle peut le prendre en photo avec sa
fantastique doigt la voiture radar à
80000 euros
mais elle ne peut pas l'arrêter comment
voulez vous que je sois favorable un
système qui consiste objectivement a
uniquement fait rentrer du fric sans
être en capacité à aucun moment
d'arrêter celui qui conduit n'importe
comment sur la route ça n'a pas de sens
si quelqu'un est dangereux il faut
l'arrêter
bon bah écoutez sur la fin je veux pas
jouer sur les mots mais c'est pas une
privatisation de cette concession de
service public un pareil oui mais non
mais je veux dire parce que moi j'ai
entendu des gens nous dire on c'est
scandaleux il tient à sa première fois
qu'on fait ça c'est pas vrai du tout à
la concession de service public ça vit
ça existe depuis le début du 20e siècle
donc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui ça c'est la
première chose ensuite
la première critique que j'ai entendu
oui les voitures les gens vont faire du
fric ils vont choisir les endroits où il
ya plus de l'accident ils vont c'est pas
vrai puisque les itinéraires sont fixés
par la gendarmerie
a priori rien d'après ce que je sais
si j'ai entendu beaucoup opa freaks et
tira sur les radars mais j'imagine bien
que si c'était un technocrate quelconque
qui avait décidé un beau jour en une
idée merveilleuse points pour faire
entrer la état détient on va mettre des
radars
et puis comme ça on va encaisser de
l'argent or il suffit qu'il suffirait
d'augmenter la tva d'un demi point on en
aurait bien plus dans les caisses
donc je vois pas pourquoi les radars
rapportent de fric c'est une pompe à
fric dans la mesure où d'abord et coûte
cher faut les acheter
il faut en assurer la maintenance et
encore plus ces temps derniers
effectivement s'est passé pas un vain
mot
et donc voilà je veux dire les radars
pompes à fric en commune iii il ya bien
d'autres manières pomper le fric avec
des résultats bien plus intéressant que
de bendera d'heure